[Música]
quinta jornada de la cob 26 en la ciudad
escocesa de glasgow la fecha coincide
con el quinto aniversario desde la
entrada en vigor del acuerdo climático
de parís justamente hoy la agencia
internacional de la energía aseguró que
con los compromisos adoptados el
calentamiento global podría mantenerse
en 1,8 grados algo que se adapta a lo
estipulado en ese documento que hablaba
de un máximo de 2 grados
unos 200 migrantes entre ellos 15
menores de edad fueron rescatados por la
guardia costera italiana en dos
operativos llevados a cabo en el mar
mediterráneo por otra parte en las
heladas aguas del canal de la mancha
miles de migrantes arriesgan sus vidas
para intentar llegar al reino unido-
reino unido se convirtió en el primer
país del mundo en aprobar el uso
condicional del molino pira beer el
primer fármaco oral para tratar el coi
19 la pastilla desarrollada por el
laboratorio merck se usará en pacientes
que cuenten con al menos un factor de
riesgo para desarrollar síntomas graves
a ustedes gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 soy valentina
torre sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos
iniciamos este informativo en la ciudad
escocesa de glasgow donde hoy se llevó a
cabo la quinta jornada de la cumbre
climática con 26 oficialmente la unión
europea de estados unidos y otros países
se comprometieron a reducir en 30% sus
emisiones de metano y 20 pactaron dejar
de financiar plantas de carbón en el
extranjero la fecha coincide con el
quinto aniversario desde la entrada en
vigor del acuerdo medioambiental de
parís desde glasgow nuestra enviada
especial marina colorado nos dio más
detalles
hoy se cumplen cinco años desde que
entró en vigor el acuerdo de parís una
firma histórica que hoy un lustro
después sigue despertando muchas dudas
acerca de su viabilidad sin embargo en
el día dedicado a la energía la agencia
internacional de este sector aseguró que
los compromisos alcanzados hoy nos
permitirían mantener el aumento de las
temperaturas en 1,9 grados algo que si
se alinearía con el objetivo del
documento entre ellos el anuncio no
vinculante que ya se supo ayer sobre la
reducción de emisiones de metano en un
30% antes de 2030 aunque con notables
ausencias como los tres mayores emisores
de este gas china india y rusia hoy se
reveló que unos 40 países incluidos
chile dejarán de invertir en nuevas
plantas de carbón dentro y fuera de sus
países y que dejarán de usarlas para
generación eléctrica entre 2030 y 2040
estados unidos y china- no se
comprometieron a este acuerdo pero sí a
dejar de financiar plantas de carbón en
el extranjero una promesa a la que se
han unido una veintena de países que
redirigirán los 8 mil millones de
dólares que dejé invertir en este
material a energías renovables la
pandemia de kobe 19 también está bien
presente en la cop 26 y se han empezado
a reportar algunos de los primeros casos
positivos aunque la onu no ha querido
confirmar cifras exactas esto preocupa a
quienes acuden a esta conferencia en la
que están registradas 39 mil 500
personas lo que la convierte en la de
mayor participación de la historia el
ministro de exteriores de francia ya
nivel edición aseguró que la cumbre
climática se está desarrollando dentro
de una dinámica positiva más allá de lo
esperado al tiempo destacó que un
acuerdo sobre mantener el calentamiento
en máximo 1,5 grados durante el siglo la
nueva meta acordada por los líderes en
el g20 haría de la cob 26 un éxito
hemos insistido el presidente lo dijo
aquí en su intervención que tenía que
haber una herramienta de control de
verificación del destino de este
financiamiento para lograr los objetivos
porque no es suficiente no es un
concurso de objetivos es una voluntad
colectiva lograr buenos resultados las
propuestas que hizo para que la ocde
pueda ser el organismo de control y de
verificación me parece que puede ser una
buena herramienta para el futuro
en otras noticias son desgarradoras las
imágenes del rescate de unos 200
migrantes en aguas del mediterráneo a
manos de la guardia costera de italia
los rescates fueron llevados a cabo en
dos operativos diferentes en uno de
ellos la guardia rescató a 74 personas a
bordo de un velero entre los que había
11 mujeres y 15 menores de edad
otros 120 migrantes fueron encontrados a
bordo de un barco pesquero de otra parte
pese al frío y al comienzo inminente del
invierno cientos de inmigrantes fueron
sacados de las heladas aguas del canal
de la mancha en su intento por alcanzar
las costas del reino unido- en dicha
travesía dos personas murieron
un retrato de pura desesperación tomada
en el mar del norte este miércoles
muestra a un migrante aferrado a la red
que cuelga de la parte trasera de un
barco de arrastre mientras él y muchos
otros intentan llegar al reino unido-
las travesías en botes de goma como
estos se han multiplicado recientemente
y los rescates también con más de 400
recuperados de forma segura el miércoles
300 del día anterior números inéditos
según los servicios de emergencia al
menos 2 migrantes han muerto en los
últimos días estos jóvenes kurdos
estaban entre los salvados de tomás
pérez en good to what you tube but había
demasiada gente en el barco este volvió
con el agua hasta aquí estuvimos en el
mar dos horas fue demasiado llamamos a
la policía y vinieron los helicópteros
white world police l culture cunit en el
norte de francia cerca de dunkerque
alrededor de 1000 están esperando su
momento en este campo improvisado cada
vez más mujeres y niños están cruzando
antes de que empeoren las condiciones
invernales y si lo intentes pero no pude
hacerlo 6 o 7 veces me ha parado la
policía y me ha capturado katz la
policía está ahora más alerta y activa
en un intento de disolver los
campamentos improvisados estás imágenes
de la semana pasada les muestran
destrozando las tiendas de campaña de
los migrantes para los activistas esto
es inaceptable por lo que dos de ellos
llevan más de tres semanas en huelga de
hambre en señal de protesta 1 l no se
debería dejar a la gente dormir a la
intemperie sin siquiera darles una carpa
y menos quitándose las autoridades han
ofrecido una noche de alojamiento de
emergencia a estos migrantes antes de
facilitarles el transporte a otros
albergues una oferta a menudo rechazada
por quienes no han arriesgado todo para
llegar tan lejos
continuamos en reino unido que se
convirtió en el primer país del mundo en
aprobar de forma condicional el fármaco
oral molt loop ir a vivir para el
tratamiento del cob y 19 sintomático en
adultos la agencia británica reguladora
de medicamentos señaló que es seguro y
efectivo para reducir el riesgo de
ingreso hospitalario y muerte en
personas con un coach de suave a
moderado que sufren un riesgo extra es
decir que de ahora en adelante será
administrado a personas con al menos un
factor de riesgo para desarrollar
síntomas graves natalia plazas tiene los
detalles
reino unido da un paso adelante para
conseguir una nueva herramienta contra
el coronavirus el país es el primero en
aprobar el uso de emergencia al
tratamiento de la farmacéutica
estadounidense merck la píldora llamada
mono pira bird es un medicamento para
prevenir los síntomas graves del cobi 19
saber broadway tener un fármaco como
éste tener un antiviral que sea potente
que se pueda tomar por vía oral es un
momento muy importante y marca un hito
en nuestro descubrimiento de
medicamentos efectivos contra el cobre
19 será aplicado a pacientes positivos
que presenten factores de riesgo como
edad avanzada complicaciones cardíacas
obesidad o diabetes el fármaco podría
reducir a la mitad las posibilidades de
muerte u hospitalización según los
estudios de la farmacéutica por el
momento no está claro cuándo llegarán
las primeras dosis al país entretanto la
agencia europea de medicamentos dijo
estar lista para aconsejar a los países
del bloque el uso de emergencia del
móvil
intentaremos acelerar nuestra evaluación
para llegar a una autorización lo antes
porque estamos entrando o ya estamos en
la cuarta ola de esta pandemia of this
pandemia tras la recomendación del ente
regulador serán los estados quienes
decidan utilizar o no el medicamento las
acciones de merck han subido como la
espuma su popularidad también crecido
después de que la compañía anunciara que
compartirá la fórmula de la píldora con
múltiples firmas para hacer llegar
rápidamente el medicamento a países con
pocos recursos
el secretario general de la organización
mundial de la salud de derosa de nong
ebre jesús hizo un nuevo llamado para
que los fabricantes de vacunas priorice
en entregar las dosis para países de
bajos ingresos sobre las de refuerzo en
naciones desarrolladas el funcionario
puntualizó que por el momento no
deberían repartirse más inyecciones
donde la cobertura es de más del 40%
excepto para las personas
inmunosuprimidas el llamado se produce
al tiempo que europa ha registrado un
nuevo repunte del 55 por ciento en los
casos en las últimas cuatro semanas
atribuido a personas que no han accedido
a vacunarse
y
seguimos escuchando excusas sobre por
qué los países de bajos ingresos sólo
han recibido el 0-4 de las vacunas del
mundo loving cup can chris hunt of war
los países de ingresos bajos no pueden
absorber las vacunas eso no es cierto
con la excepción de algunos países
frágiles afectados por conflictos y
vulnerables la mayoría de los países de
ingresos bajos están listos para
comenzar no moore vaccines good hands
no se deberían enviar más vacunas a
países que ya han vacunado a más del 40%
de su población hasta que kóvacs tenga
las vacunas que necesitan para ayudar a
otros países a llegar allí también en
kuwait tensión previa a la marcha cívica
por el cambio convocada para este 15 de
noviembre en continuación de las grandes
manifestaciones opositoras del 11 de
julio que fueron duramente reprimidas y
dejaron cientos de detenidos la protesta
fue convocada por la plataforma digital
opositora archipiélago y sus seguidores
prometieron salir a la calle pese a que
el gobierno lo prohibió argumentando una
provocación desestabilizadora de la que
culpa a estados durante la última semana
los principales dirigentes del país y
los medios oficiales han emitido
declaraciones desacreditando y
criminalizando los actos previamente
conversamos con sal y gonzález velásquez
se emprendan emprendedora y parte del
equipo promotor de la marcha quien nos
contó dos y han recibido presiones para
no manifestarse en las calles
todo el tiempo todo el tiempo la
intención que es precisamente que
nosotros no salgamos a manifestarles
pero además que las personas que nos
apoyen tampoco salgan a manifestarse las
situaciones no pagan situaciones por
parte de la policía en definitiva son
con la policía política que son los
condones del departamento de la
seguridad del estado acá en cuba-
amedrentamientos actos del repudio como
es el caso del inder garcía incluso
actos que son más ridículos pero que
están relacionados con la religión
uruguaya como lo que hicieron ayunar
garcía que el principal promotor de esta
manera íbamos a méxico porque un
enfrentamiento entre supuestos
vendedores de drogas dejó dos muertos en
la ciudad de cancún de acuerdo con la
oficina del fiscal general del estado de
quintana roo una persona fue detenida en
relación con el caso los delincuentes
portaban armas largas los hechos que
generaron pánico entre los presentes
ocurren sólo un par de semanas después
de que dos turistas murieron y tres
resultaron heridos en medio de un fuego
cruzado en la ciudad de tula
el presidente de eeuu joe biden anunció
que la vacunación será obligatoria para
toda la plantilla de las empresas con
más de 100 empleados a partir del 4 de
enero en caso de no querer vacunarse los
trabajadores deberán someterse a pruebas
semanales y también llevar mascarilla
todo el tiempo la decisión afecta a más
de 84 millones de personas y ha sido
criticada por organizaciones medianas
que han indicado que tratarán de
bloquearla al considerarla ilegal
y el gobierno estadounidense anunció que
inició conversaciones multilaterales
para aumentar la presión sobre el
presidente de nicaragua daniel ortega el
ejecutivo de joe biden indicó que
buscará formar una coalición de países y
utilizar todas las herramientas
disponibles para responder a lo que
llamó una dictadura en esa nación el
responsable de centroamérica del
departamento de estado patrick ventrell
aseguró que las elecciones
presidenciales que se llevarán a cabo
este domingo no tienen credibilidad y
según dijo son una farsa 7 precandidatos
opositores además de una treintena de
detractores han sido encarcelados en los
últimos meses
y en noticias del continente asiático
peng shuai quien fuera número uno del
mundo en dobles de tenis acusó
públicamente a un ex vice primer
ministro chino de forzarla a mantener
relaciones sexuales varios años atrás la
publicación hecha en redes sociales fue
rápidamente borrada y ha disparado una
ola masiva de censura en todo el país
más en el siguiente informe
una concepción explosiva puesto al radar
de la censura china trabajar a marcha
forzada pensó hay una de las principales
estrellas deportivas del país ha acusado
al político sangalli de cuestionar la a
tener relaciones sexuales hace años todo
comenzó con una publicación de la cuenta
verificada de peng shuai en la gigante
red social china weibo la carta abierta
sostiene que existe una relación con
zhang aol y durante periodos
intermitentes que se extendió por al
menos 10 años 20 am bien acusa al ex
vice primer ministro y miembro del
máximo cuerpo de toma de decisiones del
país de forzarlo a tener sexo hace tres
años la publicación fue borrada a 30
minutos después y detonó una ola de
censura en línea las búsquedas con el
nombre de pena en portales chinos no
muestran resultados y se ha bloqueado
interacciones como compartir o comentar
sobre el post original en su lugar
aparece este mensaje
lo sentimos no se puede completar esta
acción porque la publicación incluye
contenido que viola las leyes son las
reglas de la comunidad de weibo esto fue
lo que dijo el vocero del ministerio del
exterior cuando se le consultó sobre la
censura
no he oído sobre este tema no es una
cuestión relacionada con asuntos
exteriores próxima pregunta
las autoridades chinas no se han
pronunciado ni se ha hecho cobertura de
las denuncias en medios de comunicación
locales en 2018 el movimiento a mitú en
china ganó impulso cuando un estudiante
de una universidad de beijing acusó a su
profesor de acoso sexual lo que llegó
hasta las organizaciones no
gubernamentales a la prensa y a la
industria del entretenimiento pero es
primera vez que un político importante
es públicamente acusado de forzar
sexualmente a alguien
[Música]
así llegamos al final de esta emisión de
noticias a ustedes gracias por su
sintonía y recuerden que pueden ampliar
toda la información y repetir este y
otros programas en nuestra web france24
puntocom continúen con nosotros que
volvemos con más aquí en france 24
[Música]